hey Vsauce Michael here and are you
still doing things in the real world
come on
I mean why flip a coin when you could
just flip a coin calm every time you
refresh the page it flips again of
course there are plenty of other things
you can do online now guys for instance
have you ever wondered am i awesome
we'll ask the Internet go to a my
awesome dot-com it never lies earn your
awesomeness like once tuned by playing
the wiki game against opponents from all
over the world Here I am clicking links
to race from the US Constitution to
South India I had a rough patch there in
the middle but I got by in a squeaker
the constellations in the sky have
looked the way they do since the ancient
people gave them names but they are
still fleeting because our earth moves
and the solar system moves and the
galaxy is moving all through space they
won't always look the same this website
shows you what will happen to them in
the future for instance 70,000 years
from today standing on earth the Big
Dipper will look like this if cosmonauts
explore the cosmos and you explore the
internet that makes you an Internet and
internauts love confrontation
specifically the disagreeing
internet.com begin from here
and the internet will constantly be
shaking its head at you in pyro you aim
flaming balls to start fires and burn
things but to test your wits try the
impossible quiz multiple-choice
questions that make you think
can a matchbox no but a tin can
the a master 15 pointed me towards this
incredible depository of giant images
like really really giant following the
rules is safe and easy for instance
deliver okay done but when a level says
disobeyed don't do what it says
Ozzy Ziggy recommends mother look where
you play as a machine that can burrow
but also jump pretty well make money
collecting rock to upgrade and don't
forget to refuel stealing the diamond
lets you make choices and see how they
pan out be careful and creative for a
string of bizarre clips the best 404
page ever calm always offers a pleasant
surprise but take a break and relax with
two PlayStation Network and play in the
sand because this is sand calm and oh
look Amy Poehler has a channel on
YouTube with lots of different kinds of
stuff including her answering your
questions while she lies on a bed or
sits in a shower it's for smart girls
but yes there is a weekly boy minute
the Chilango asks you to test out
passwords at how secure is my password
net the site estimates and displays how
quickly a PC could guess your password
does that make you nervous
well hissing pixels is here to calm you
down with the nicest place on the
internet it's nothing but a never-ending
parade of fullscreen videos of people
hugging you writer's block will be like
tech on your six and generate yourself
some plots this site randomly creates
scenarios to get you thinking Ranger
forceful recommends last square standing
which is super simple but gets tough
quick avoid touching anything for as
long as you can
pointer pointer watches your pointer and
then pulls a photo from its giant
reservoir in which someone points to
where your pointer is finally surf that
sugg asked has the Large Hadron Collider
the world yet dot-com whoo okay looks
like we're good for now but let's
periodically check on this to make sure
the world is still together and if it is
or even if it isn't as always thanks for
watching
[Music]